I don't even know where to begin Tamera
Mowry Housley is saying goodbye to the
real the actress has been a co-host on
the daytime talk show for seven years
and has been on the series since its
debut in 2013 you have to make sure that
you do your research about what you
bring to the table Tamera announced her
exit on social media posting this note
to Instagram and Twitter to my fellow
hosts I love you I will miss you and I
will always be there for you thank you
for teaching me supporting me and loving
all of me sisters forever I'll be
rooting for you as I look forward to
spending more time with my family
pursuing amazing opportunities and
embarking on the next chapter of my life
but not only that we stayed
authentically true to ourselves in the
note Tamera referenced the awards she's
received for her work on the series
including a Daytime Emmy and two
n-double-a-cp
Image Awards how does the sound of Emmy
winners the news comes just one month
after former co-host Amanda seals
announced her exit from the real the
comedian had joined the series six
months prior my contract is up at the
reel and I did not renew it
because it doesn't feel good to my soul
to be at a place where I cannot speak to
my people the way they need to be spoken
to and where the people who are speaking
to me in disparaging ways are not being
handled Steele said at the time that her
departure had nothing to do with her
co-hosts on the series but she did cite
issues with people behind the scenes I'm
not in a space where I can as a full
black woman have my voice and my
co-workers also have their voices and
where the people at the top are not
respecting the necessity for black
voices to be at the top to
[Music]